je veux un rouge
voilà
maintenant
monsieur tête j'en veux une autre citron
toi toi aussi
au revoir
mes amis mais très cher ça se passe
quelque chose de terrible toutes mes
carottes ont disparu
et vous pensez que ceux qui ont fait ça
voulais ma chère amie en fait cette fois
là c'était Casimir qui interprète
le langage
marquer aucune trace dans votre potager
justement
reconnaître des traces de renard
allô ici Julie c'est toi Léonard
tu as quitté ta mal pour aller chercher
les carottes dans le potager de monsieur
du snob
non non ne t'inquiète pas les enfants
vont venir tout de suite
je pense que vous avez compris en
revenant du potager le monsieur du snob
Léonard a trouvé ça mal fermée de
l'intérieur
le couvercle a dû rester coincé
mais non il dit qu'il entend des bruits
étranges qui a pris 4 ans quelqu'un
dedans
Casimir il est en promenade paraît-il
les enfants venez venez vite j'ai besoin
de vous
nous allons nous rendre dans la maison
de Casimir
[Musique]
Léonard Thurre
je suis là
[Musique]
tu as une idée mais on a
et voulait trouve-t-on les hérissons en
campagne
une autre proposition
qu'est-ce que ça fait sous la terre et
eau
Stéphane
[Musique]
ça vit dans l'eau oui tu as raison
ensuite
ça vit sous la terre et sa loge dans un
terrier
petit écureuil
ça vit dans les arbres les écureuils ça
mange quoi les écureuils
les noisettes
tu as raison
alors nous avons les enfants qui s'agit
soit d'une taupe soit d'un mulot soit
des lapins soin d'une belette
le couvercle à bouger
regarde
ça alors Casimir mais que fais-tu
là-dedans
je voulais profiter de l'absence de
Léonard pour visiter sa maison mais je
crois que je suis un peu trop gros et je
suis resté coincé